hi i'm steven crowder and today i will
be reading the green New Deal in its
five-page entirety the reason for this
is full transparency unlike our
colleagues at fox or The Young Turks as
well as to see if people are actually
interested in reading substantive
policies if you want to call this that
and seeing if we get D monetized I will
be doing nothing else recognizing this
is the whole green New Deal word for
word
recognizing the duty of the federal
government to create a green new deal
whereas the October 2018 report entitled
special report on global warming of 1.5
degrees Celsius by the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change in November 2018
fourth National Climate Assessment
report found that one human activity is
a dominant cause of observed climate
change over the past century to a
changing climate is causing sea levels
to rise and an increase in wildfires
severe storms draughts and other extreme
weather events that threaten human life
health communities and critical
infrastructure three global warming at
or above two degrees Celsius beyond pre
industrialized levels will cause a mass
migration from the Murray mass migration
from the region's most affected by
climate change be more than 500 billion
dollars in lost annual economic output
in the United States by the year 2100 C
wildfires that by 2050 will annually
burn at least twice as much forest area
in the western United States than was
typically burned by wildfires in the
years preceding 2019 D a loss of more
than 99% of all coral reefs on earth e
more than 350 million more people to be
exposed globally to deadly heat stress
by 2050 and F a risk of damage to 1
trillion dollars of public
infrastructure and coastal real estate
in the United States and for global
temperatures must be kept below 1.5
degrees Celsius above pre-industrial
levels to avoid the most severe impacts
of a changing climate which will require
- - a global reductions in greenhouse
gas emissions from human sources of 40
to 60 percent from 2010 levels by 2030
and be Net Zero global emissions by 2050
whereas because the United States has
historically been responsible for a
disproportionate amount of greenhouse
gas emissions having emitted 20% of
global greenhouse gas emissions through
2014 and has a high technological
capacity the United States must take a
leading role in reducing emissions
through economic transformation whereas
the United States is currently
experiencing several related crises with
one life expectancy declining while
basic needs such as clean air clean
water healthy food and adequate health
care housing transportation and
education are inaccessible to a
significant portion of the United States
population - a decade trend of wage
stagnation deindustrialization and anti
labor policies that has led to a hourly
wages overall stagnating since the 1970s
despite increased worker productivity be
the third worst level of socio-economic
mobility in the developed world before
the Great Recession
see the erosion of the earning and
bargaining power of workers in the
United States ND inadequate resources
for public sector workers to confront
the challenges of climate change at
local state and federal levels and three
the greatest income inequality since the
1920s with a the top 1% of earners
accruing 91 percent of gains in the
first few years of economic recovery
after the Great Recession be a large
racial wealth divide that's how it's
written be a large racial wealth divide
amounting to a difference of 20 times
more wealth between the average white
family and the average black family
semicolon and see a gender earnings gap
that results in women earning
approximately eighty percent as much as
men at the median semicolon
whereas climates now we're back to
another indentation where as climate
change pollution and environmental
destruction have exacerbated systemic
racial regional social environmental and
economic and justices parentheses
referred to in this preamble as systemic
and Justices by disproportionately
affecting indigenous peoples communities
of color migrant communities the
industrialized communities depopulated
rural communities - poor low-income
workers women the elderly the unhoused
people with disabilities , and youth
referred to in this preamble as
frontline and vulnerable communities in
parentheses semi-colon whereas climate
change constitutes a direct threat to
the national security of the United
States one by impacting the economic
environmental and social stability of
countries and communities around the
world and two by acting as a threat
multiplier whereas the federal
government led mobilizations during
World War two and the New Deal created
the greatest middle class that the
United States has ever seen but many
members of front-line and vulnerable
communities were excluded from many of
the economic and social benefits of
these mobilizations
and whereas the House of Representatives
recognizes that a new national social
industrial and economic mobilization on
the scale not seen since World War two
and the New Deal era is his is a
historic opportunity one to create
millions of good high wage jobs in the
United States two to provide
unprecedented levels of prosperity and
economic security for all people of the
United States and three to counteract
systemic and Justices now , therefore ,
be it resolved that it is that it is the
sense of the House of Representatives
that one it is the duty of the federal
government to create a green new deal
there we go
Hey to achieve the net zero greenhouse
gas emissions through a fair and just
transition for all communities and
workers B to create millions of good
high wage jobs and ensure prosperity and
economic security for all people of the
United States C to invest in the
infrastructure and industry of the
United States to sustainably meet
challenges of the 21st century D to
secure for all people the United States
for generations to come
one clean air and water to climate and
community resiliency three healthy food
for access to nature and five
sustainable environment
and II to promote justice and equity by
stopping current preventing future and
repairing historic oppression of
indigenous peoples communities of color
migrant communities the industrialize
communities depopulated rural
communities the poor low-income workers
women the elderly the unhoused people
with disabilities and youth referred to
in this resolution as frontline remote
rural communities
no okay it just repeated its I'm sorry I
thought I had the wrong page because
it's the exact same thing No
page three number two the goal is
described in subparagraphs A through E
of paragraph one parentheses referred to
in this resolution as the green New Deal
goals should be accomplished through a
ten-year national mobilization
parentheses referred to in this
resolution as the green New Deal
mobilization that will require the
following goals and projects a building
resiliency against climate change
related disasters such as extreme
weather including by leveraging funding
and providing investments for community
to find projects and strategies be
repairing and upgrading the
infrastructure in the United States
including one by eliminating pop by
eliminating pollution and greenhouse gas
emissions as much as technologically
feasible - by guaranteeing universal
access to clean water three by reducing
the risks posed by climate impacts and
four by ensuring that any infrastructure
bill considered by Congress addresses
climate change see meeting 100% of the
power demand the United States do clean
renewable and zero emission energy
sources including one by dramatically
expanding and upgrading renewable power
resources and two by deploying new
capacity D building or upgrading to
energy-efficient distributed and smart
power grids and ensuring affordable
access to electricity e upgrading all
existing buildings in the United States
and building new buildings to achieve
maximum energy efficiency water
efficiency safety affordability comfort
and durability including through
electrification F spurring massive
growth and clean manufacturing in the
United States and removing pollution and
greenhouse gas emissions from bring an
industry as much as technologically
feasible including by expanding
renewable
energy manufacturing and investing in
existing manufacturing and Industry G
working collaboratively with farmers and
ranchers in the United States to remove
pollution and greenhouse gas emissions
from the agricultural sector as much as
technologically feasible including one
by supporting family farming two by
investing in sustainable farming and
land use practices that increased soil
health and three by building a more
sustainable food system that ensures
universal access to healthy food e -
what my beak here this is this is not in
the bill H overhauling transportation
systems in the United States to remove
pollution and greenhouse gas emissions
from the transportation sector as much
as it is technologically feel
technologically feasible including
through investments in one zero emission
vehicle infrastructure and manufacturing
to clean affordable and acts and
accessible public transit and three
high-speed rail one mitigating and
managing the long-term adverse health
economic and other effects of pollution
and climate change including by
providing funding for community to find
projects and strategies Jay removing
greenhouse gases from the atmosphere and
reducing pollution by restoring natural
ecosystems through proven low-tech
solutions that increase soil carbon
storage such as land preservation and
deforestation with you a second
keh restoring and protecting threatened
endangered and fragile ecosystems
through locally appropriate and
science-based projects that enhance
biodiversity and supporting climate
resiliency l cleaning up existing
hazardous waste and abandoned sites
ensuring economic development and
sustainability on those sites M
identifying other emission and pollution
sources and creating solutions to remove
them and n promoting the international
exchange of technology expertise
products funding and services with the
aim of making the United States the
international leader on climate action
and to help other countries achieve a
green new deal 3 a green new deal must
be developed through transparent and
inclusive consultation collaboration and
partnership with frontline and
vulnerable communities labor unions
worker cooperatives civil society groups
academia and businesses and for to
achieve the green New Deal goals and
mobilization a green new deal will
require the following goals and projects
a providing and leveraging in a way that
ensures that the public receives
appropriate ownership stakes and returns
on investment adequate capital including
through community grants public banks
and other public financing technical
expertise supporting policies and other
forms of assistance to communities
organizations federal state and local
government agencies and businesses
working on the green New Deal
mobilization B ensuring that the federal
government takes into account the
complete environmental and social costs
and impacts of emissions through one
existing laws to new policies and
programs and three ensuring that
frontline and vulnerable communities
shall not be adversely affected C
providing resources training and high
quality education including higher
education to all people of the United
States with a focus on frontline and
vulnerable communities so that all
people of the United States may be full
and equal participants in the green New
Deal mobilization D making public
investments in the research and
development of new clean and renewable
energy technologies and industries e
directing investments to spur economic
development d
and diversify industry and business and
local and regional economies and build
wealth and community ownership while
prioritizing high-quality job creation
and economic social and environmental
benefits in front-line and vulnerable
communities and the industrialized
communities that may otherwise struggle
with the transition away from greenhouse
gas intensive industries one phrase F
ensuring the use of democratic I'm
trying not to editorialize read along
just follow the bouncing crazy F
ensuring the use of democratic and
participatory processes that are
inclusive of and led by frontline and
vulnerable communities and workers to
plan implement and administer the green
New Deal mobilization at the local level
G ensuring that the green New Deal
mobilization creates high-quality union
jobs that pay prevailing wages hire
local workers hires excuse me local
workers offers training and advancement
opportunities and guarantees wage and
benefit parity for workers affected by
the transition H guaranteeing a job with
a family sustaining wage adequate family
and medical leave paid vacations and
retirement security to all people of the
United States i strengthening and
protecting light of all workers to
organize unionize and collectively
bargain free of coercion intimidation
and harassment strengthening and
enforcing labor workplace health and
safety anti-discrimination and wage and
hour standards across all employers
industries and sectors k and acting and
enforcing trade rules procurement
standards and border adjustments with
strong labor and environmental
protections one to stop the transfer of
jobs and pollution overseas and two to
grow domestic manufacturing in the
United States L L ensuring that public
lands waters and oceans are protected
and that eminent domain is not abused M
obtaining the free prior and informed
consent of indigenous peoples for all
decisions that affect indigenous peoples
and their traditional territories
honoring all treaties and agreements
with indigenous peoples and protecting
and enforcing the sovereignty and land
rights of indigenous peoples and
ensuring a community environment where
every business person is free from
unfair competition and domination by
domestic or international monopolies and
Oh providing all people of the United
States with one high-quality health care
- affordable safe and adequate housing 3
Economic Security and for clean water
clean air healthy and affordable food
and access to nature and Bill now the
reason I did that I don't know why I did
that
if you like this video subscribe to the
channel or hit the notification bell do
it I'll wait a second do you hear that
little ding it actually did make a ding
sound I just did it would happen while
my mouth was doing it and you thought it
was coming from your computer so that's
fun also there's some videos playing in
these boxes next to me go watch those
you might enjoy them you might not you
don't care